[Music]
with today's technology we should be
able to hear another person's thoughts
it would be better if we had a human
Henri's human not for me three what must
have been a power outage last night when
Oliver makes an incredible discovery
make way for the total package brains
personality and good looks things will
never be the same
[Music]
genius so old ox and understand all
humans duh but you can't tell anybody
that's checkmate sucka makes me yawn the
occupation this main thing is baked for
you good luck at the fair now he must
make sure his new invention the skin
especially doesn't fall into the wrong
hands
oh my god it works you didn't I would do
anything to acquire this technology sit
shiny not hungry
wait what no one said there be snacks
they've got adventure my human is in
trouble and I need your help
Oh didn't know you're having an awesome
party down to a science
you're gonna save Oliver Gabriel Bateman
Kunal Nayyar with Megan Fox and Josh
Duhamel
oh we make a good team Henry
[Music]
think like a dog you smell as many butts
as I have you tend to pick up a few
things
[Music]